hey what's up you guys welcome to
another episode of get close i am your
host co-host gio i'm bart and today we
have
one cool
mf mofo here attached nguyen i am so
excited to have you here um i've seen
you just explode on instagram like
uh so if you guys don't know who he is
he is seattle-based um realtor
entrepreneur philanthropist
um dad husband just a complete
shark
ass [ __ ]
yes yes and i like the first video i
ever saw of you i was like man there is
something really special about you like
there is something just so electric and
so authentic and so real that like i
wasn't even trying to hear about like
real estate or any of that stuff but as
soon as you spoke i was just captivated
i was like oh
this guy's speaking to me he's speaking
my language i love it
it was really cool because like you know
like in your space the information that
people tend to share is pretty stale yes
it's pretty like
uh kind of boring it is boring and then
it feels like the person trying to share
the information is sharing it more from
a space of like this is what i know and
this is why i'm successful and it's i i
there's just this huge disconnect for me
at least right yeah sometimes like i
asked my real estate agent friends not
to put them on blast but i'll ask them a
question
because i don't understand what's going
on right i'm like yo uh what does this
mean right and by the time they answer
i'm even more confused hey i'm like man
i'm not gonna ask you anything anymore
right but you when i asked you one
question and just clear concise
voicemail right i was like dude i
completely get what he's talking about
and that's what i get from your videos
too where it's just short concise very
informational and then now people have
uh like a take away of what they can do
immediately and apply it right and i
think speaking upon like the like the
charisma and the delivery and all that
that we get from the videos
um everything that you're speaking you
can tell it's from a place of experience
right like truth
struggles ups and downs
so like for the people that don't know
how you got to where you are now like
what's um like what's your story like
how how did it all start and everything
yeah man i appreciate that um you know
i wasn't like that early on if you guys
would have knew me maybe 10 15 years ago
i was more of those type of realtor
oh the boring one boring one yeah i mean
and um
and
you know
it starts to evolve and the cocoons
start to open up uh to get where i'm at
today but
when did you start yeah so you know
we're going to talk a lot about where i
am today but let me rewind it yeah
anybody can actually know you know i
wasn't born with this gift i wasn't born
with the money i have i'm born with all
this great blessing you weren't born
with the rolls royce man i wish i would
you know me
but um but i was born in um in vietnam
in 1970
uh my dad went for the u.s military and
my mom was staying home
my mom was 29 years old my dad was 34
she was pregnant my sister at the time i
had four brothers
and my sister you know was pregnant my
mom and my dad was at work one day and
this is in 75. this is back in vietnam
about vietnam
and and i know uh you know everyone out
there can listen can relate to this
because we all been there somewhere
somehow in our family story
um but my dad
um get a phone call my mom get a phone
call at home during lunch time she said
my dad said hey pack your bags
i'm kind of come home and get you guys
because we just got word that the
vietnamese communist is invading south
vietnam in 20 in 48 hours holy [ __ ] and
the u.s government is pulling out now so
when you see all those
pbs you know uh uh television where the
helicopter is flying out of embassy yeah
we was part of that whole thing right
wow so
my dad called home until my mom pack up
yeah i'm gonna come get you guys we're
leaving with the u.s troop because if
you're a vietnamese person working for
the u.s government oh you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] up right they're gonna
kill you yeah i mean yeah and so
my dad said you know we gotta leave so
he got home my mom put everybody you
know uh together um i was five years old
at the time right i'm the fourth in nine
i got three older brother i got a
younger brother and then my sister
obviously was pregnant uh my mom uh so
so she was traveling with that baby
and um we put everything in one suitcase
and we had like 100 bucks
and we got to the jeep and we drove to
the airport on our way to the airport
we blew two tires oh my god
so i want people who's out there
listening
34 29 a family of you know you know
eight traveling leaving the country and
so this is this is what's 54 29. that's
how old my dad was oh okay
and then my mom
so my dad was the one who actually had
the courage to actually
take us put us in this environment today
right yeah so we blew to tire
he got out he managed to fix both tires
after a lot of work
we get to the airport and we miss the
last plane flying out oh my god okay
and
after a few hours he finally got ahold
of his boss and the boss says stay in
saigon
tomorrow morning
all right meet us at this location will
get you guys into this truck because
nobody know we're evacuating and then
you guys can fly out with us
so my dad decided to stay in the jeep
all of us sleeping upstairs because he
didn't want nobody to steal the jeep
yeah
we get in the morning we all get to
early early in the morning to this gas
station and we get it out of the jeep
we'll get into this u-haul truck where
they close the door
there's a bunch of people in there
that's all part of the military uh uh
people
and we got into the airport they open up
the door chaos everywhere everybody's
running around trying to get on this
plane
we got on the last plane luckily we flew
out we landed in san diego that's why
southern california has such a big
population of vietnamese yeah that was
where a lot of them landed we stay there
at camp pendleton they use that it's the
homeless shelter
stay there for about a month or so and
then governor evans from washington
state decided to pull a lot of the
family up to washington state to help
spread the migration oh cool so my dad
decided to go to seattle yeah where the
first family actually stepped
foot on washington soil
right and we stayed there for about two
months or so
in the shelter
you can't leave the shelter unless
someone sponsor you out in the shelter
so a gentleman in charge who live who
worked at the shelter where decided to
sponsor my mom and a whole family to
live with them
and they did a lot of amazing things
with our family they used to drive my
dad into work you know i mean 45 minutes
one way she go back home drive back into
work you know and get him back home and
she was like in her 50s
right and so that's where
when i was younger
i didn't realize the contribution
someone did for our family yeah that's
why part of the reason why i do a lot of
philanthropic work today is for giving
back to charles zetland his mom and
helping us yeah and so
uh my dad
became a social worker up in seattle
finally we got into a little house two
bedroom one bath house um
eight of us lived there and then we
started our life from there man and uh
and um my dad my mom would stay home mom
i went to school like everybody else i
got teas and i was young coming up you
know me that you know the funny like the
only asian kid oh yeah the only asian
kid in in that community
um and you know i had multiple paper
routes to come up you know and i
graduated from high school in 88 i
wasn't
i wasn't the smartest kid on the block
but i also
had good grade all the way up to senior
year until i met a bunch of groups where
we just hung out in in our senior year
where i didn't get good grades
and when i graduate 88 i wasn't sure
what i wanted to do i followed my two
older brother footsteps on doing
aviation fixing airplanes
i got my degree fixed airplane 91 and i
hated it
and i didn't really want to go
uh fixed airplane out of state so i
decided to stay home i worked at
safeway
full time
with a grocery store
a body shop and we're at a chinese
restaurant chinatown park and cars that
was my three job i worked seven days a
week and i was just making money and i
was sitting at a chinese restaurant and
my friend linda who's
the daughter's owner they were studying
for the real estate license
and they're they were like hey man you
should do real estate with us we gotta
go get a license you'd be good at it and
i was like really
and i'm like okay were you already good
with people and good yeah why do you
think you were good at it
because they said i had a mouthpiece
oh okay they had a mouthpiece yeah right
so you just like to talk and talk about
you know yeah yeah
i got my license at 21 years old i was
clueless
and i started my real estate career at
21 years old
and i was living on my mom and dad
for the first three years i just went to
the office sat around i didn't know what
to do how did your parents feel about
that you know how asian folks is man you
should be a doctor you should be a
lawyer you should be a nurse you should
be a pharmacist even back then yeah bro
it never changes they still do it today
you know what i mean hey
i always tell my dad my daughter wanted
me to be a doctor i'm like man you ain't
even the doctor dude
come on man
and that's what i say to a lot of asian
folks out there man it's like you know i
i love my parents i know you all love
your parents out there the minority
especially you know and sometimes our
parents just think that the only way to
be successful is a doctor a lawyer
what's safe right it's safe they've seen
the path they're like i know you're
going down the right way and it's a
prestige thing for them to brag
my daughter is this my son is that you
know what i mean and to be honest a lot
of them aren't even rich a lot of
doctors out there you know what i mean
and so
i got my british license 21 i didn't do
nothing
for three years in 1994 i met a guy
he's a real estate mentor
and he said you want to do real estate
right you got to learn how to go out
there and find listings there's two ways
you can do business you can sit around
wait for somebody or you can go out
there and create your own business and i
was like i'm listening what i got to do
right and i hired him as a coach it was
300 bucks for a half an hour call once a
month wow and it says that's probably a
lot back then dude that's all my money
you know what i mean is that like
considered like three grand today or
like 10 grand bro oh [ __ ] right for 30
minutes 30 minutes well wait before you
even continue like it takes a certain
type of mindset to want to even uh
devote so much into it right because you
were making money you said you could
have been comfortably making like 25 g's
you know i mean a year leaving my mom i
was actually comfortable you know what i
mean yeah why why what what clicked or
what changed or what were you looking at
that you're like wait this isn't this
isn't where i want to stay good
you know
i think everybody
have dreams and hopes
and i made a video the other day and i
said
hope and dream
is the most important thing if you let
that die then there's no point waking up
yeah yeah that's true right there's no
purpose there's no purpose
and i think everybody out there right
don't let nobody discourage you from
dreaming and hoping
telling you can't do it because the
moment you give up then that's when you
don't want to wake up anymore yeah for
me
there was nobody around me you know what
i mean i told me i couldn't do it that
you couldn't do it i thought your
parents were the ones saying like they
said today they used to go do doctors
and everything right yeah but they
didn't tell me i i couldn't dream big i
see i see right yeah and so i wanted to
make money just like everybody else when
they were young right and
and the the good and the bad thing was
i lived in an area
where you know there's a lot of people
that did illegal things that make a lot
of money have nice cars and everything
and i wanted the nice stuff what kind of
stuff are they doing yeah yeah man
you know you know selling drugs in the
streets you know what i mean all that
kind of stuff right and i knew a lot of
them you know what i mean
and i still know a lot of them a lot of
immigrant asian communities there's just
a lot of asian games and stuff like that
yeah right
and so did you ever participate in uh
maybe in a non non-illegal
way i was
and and honestly i i have no problem
sharing these stories
i was i got in trouble for association
oh okay and
that is as bad
as actually doing the dirt right yeah i
didn't know that yeah all right and we
can we can we can talk about that more
that story here also i'm happy to say i
have no problem sharing everything you
know what i mean yeah because
i came up from that same area where
everybody came up at right i just made
the best of it you know what i mean yeah
so i was inspired to make more money
and i seen what my mom and dad work you
know my mom was a factory worker my dad
was a social worker
and
i see people in real estate at the time
you know drive a nice car knowing well
and most of them are today they still
don't make no money they drive a nice
car so i got inspired i got my real
estate license and i remember this guy
mike told me look you want to be
successful you got to go spend time
looking for listings and i said how do
you look for listing you got to go cold
condor knock them i'm like that's it
and he teaches me right he coaches me
how know what to say
like straight up see a house and then
you're like hey this has potential and
just go hey you want to sell your family
knock every door on the neighborhood wow
so nine o'clock in the morning i have
this schedule
i told my wife cammy drop me off take
the car
because i know if i if i had the car out
there i wouldn't get out of the car oh
hey so smart i had to set myself up for
success did you take your shoes too or
not all right
take the shoes take the shoes
he took off i said look i'm gonna call
you after i finish doing lock and then
come back get me okay
so he's dropping off nine o'clock i had
a hundred flyers and i made a commitment
i'm going to do like 100 a day
if they're home i'm going to talk to
them i'm going to give them a flyer if
they're not home i'm going to leave the
fly out the front door but i know i've
knocked i know
i'm not going to do it because i'm a
passive on the flyer
and it took me five hours to knock on
100 doors
i did it monday through friday five
hours a day five days a week and i
started my career in 94 knocking on the
door so i just got dropped off in the
area and i just went from door to door
to door to door asking people the script
and i read the script to them how to
memorize and
man the first year it was go learn how
to speak english um right
i didn't ask you just come to my house
i'm not selling don't ever come back to
my house right get off my porch you know
what i mean go somewhere in english and
that would that was like what it was 99
door slamming the door on me slam on the
door and be slamming the door at me
and it was raining it's cold and you're
out there by yourself and you know i was
only battling 24 years old you know yeah
and man i i just had this vision what
kept me going with the vision of
rolls-royce
retiring my mom and dad
oh that's beautiful
that's beautiful tired my mom and dad
you know when you're knocking like for
five hours a day like
real estate there's no
like wages or salaries no bro it's a
commission commission so how do you get
by like let's say i don't know the first
couple months i lived at home
i lived at home yeah and my vision was
i'm gonna help retire my mom and dad
that's awesome
and
every time i get a door slam
i just have to remind myself
why i'm doing it yeah right that's
beautiful that's my why yeah right
that's awesome i got back up
i did the next door
i hear another rejection
i just gotta keep moving yeah i keep
telling myself i got to keep moving
and i knew every time i knocked on the
door i'm just going to get better
yeah
i did it every day five days a week five
hours a day right every day right yeah
and the first year
i sold like five or six homes oh sick
i had a little momentum
but it was hard man the rain was coming
out on me people you know i mean
cursing at me
racist comment on me right because i was
one of the
few asian realtors in the area that's 24
years old knocking on neighborhood and
agent in the area talking about get out
of my neighborhood those are my
neighborhoods you can't be farming my
neighborhood right nobody own no
neighborhood in the area right yeah yeah
second year
i got out again
and i did it every day hundred dollars a
day i knocked on 100 doors a day you
guys 11 000 doors a year damn i did it
every day
second year i did 10 home third year i
did you know i mean 20 home i did it
every day
for 10 years straight i didn't miss a
day doing it every single day i went 20
home 30 home 40 home 50 home
and then in my third in my fourth year
with mike
i was making close to a million dollars
a year wow at a realtor knocking on 100
a day five days a week damn and every
day my mindset got stronger and i tell
everybody right my mindset you build
mindset through practicing
focusing on what you want speaking into
existence and you got to keep your foot
moving forward that's the only way you
can build mental toughness you can't
build mental toughness sitting around
meditating you build mental toughness
from putting the foot in front of the
next foot in the next foot and just keep
speaking you go into existence and just
keep telling people what you're doing
and just keep it moving that's how you
build mental discipline that's how you
build hunger that's how you build mental
toughness and that's what i did every
single day yeah and i did that every
single day and i became a millionaire at
age 27 three four years later that's
incredible yeah every day bro
okay so let's take a minute real quick
to thank our sponsor skylight frames
i absolutely love that skylight frames
exists because we are in the thick of
holiday gifting season
and if you're like me you're racking
your brain right now going what do i
give
to people that i really care about or
people that have everything or people
that i just haven't been able to see you
know for the past two years
skylight frame is perfect for that
skylight frame is a digital photo frame
that you can update instantly by email
from anywhere it is a great way to feel
close to those that you love
and when you're separated i gifted one
of these to my mom a few years back
and till this day i email
you know photos to the account they
instantly get uploaded into her frame in
california i'm in nevada
and i'll get a text from her randomly
and she's like you added another photo
didn't you this is so cute and it makes
her day we are going to be gifting these
this year as well to our loved ones that
we just haven't been able to see we're
going to be spending christmas out here
without family so this is the perfect
opportunity for us
to email holiday photos or just photos
throughout the year that we just haven't
been able to share with them now as a
special offer you can get 10 off your
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylightframe.com
and enter code bill b-e-a-w
that's right 10
off your purchase of a skylight frame
just go to skylight
skylightframe.com and enter code bell
b-e-a-w
that's s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e
dot com
again promo code bill thank you to our
sponsor daily harvest
ah
the holidays all the get-togethers the
gift planning and then there's trying to
juggle work in between all of this
craziness my schedule for sure is always
thrown out of whack during this time of
the year um tyke is about to be let out
of school he's gonna be out of school
for two weeks we have no family unit out
here so it is going to get hectic so i'm
so grateful that daily harvest delivers
delicious harvest bowls flatbreads
smoothies and more all built on organic
fruits vegetables right to our door and
your door
and it conveniently stays fresh in your
freezer
i
love this service because it's
thoughtless sometimes i'm just go go go
go go i go into my freezer and i know
that i'm gonna pick something nutritious
when i have daily harvest i'm not gonna
feel guilty about preservatives i'm not
gonna feel guilty about you know added
sugars and just junk food that i'm
putting in my body because i have no
time to really think about it so daily
harvest is a life saver you guys do not
sleep on it please do yourself a favor
and order some daily harvest all you
have to do is go to dailyharvest.com
to get up to 40 off your first box
that's daily harvest dot com slash bill
b e a w for up to forty dollars off your
first box daily harvest dot com
slash bill thank you to our sponsor
story worth okay so story worth is an
online service that helps you and your
loved ones preserve precious memories
and stories for years to come
it is a thoughtful and meaningful gift
that connects you to those who matter
the most so this is how it works okay
every week story worth emails your
relative or friend a thought-provoking
question of your choice from their vast
pool of possible options okay so each
unique prompt asks questions you've
never thought to ask like
what's the bravest thing you've ever
done in your life or if you could see
into the future
what would you want to find out so as
you can already see it's building a
story
and it's gonna do this for one year okay
so after one year story worth will
compile all your loved ones stories
including photos uh into a beautiful
keepsake book that you'll be able to
share and revisit for generations to
come isn't that amazing
like
it's gonna be it's like your own family
book like at your own family crest if
you will um so with story worth i'm
giving those i love the most thoughtful
personal gift from my heart or the heart
and preserving our memories and stories
for years to come so to get your hands
on this go to storyworth.com
bill b-e-a-w and save ten dollars on
your first purchase that's
storyworth.combill
to save ten dollars on your first
purchase do you look at the generation
now i just go man everyone's a person
today
today people ask me all the time how do
you keep your kid hungry that's the only
one question they asked me all the time
yeah i was about to ask you that's
everyone's goal right to
uh do well for their family right but
the problem is when you do well for your
family your next generation don't have
the same struggles yeah and if they
don't have the same struggles not the
same great not the same mental toughness
so how do you create or how do you
create environment where
your family does do better but then
still have the same great question yeah
same mindset my wife cami
is the beast in the house
nice my wife cami
says
i don't want to make it easy for russell
hudson
i want them to struggle
this that's your 13 year old and 16 year
old son
i want him to how do you do that like
when they're taking a hot shower he's
turning cold real quick right
hide all their clothes yeah that's close
right which is so
she i'm more of a softer than her
cammy says
if you want keep them hungry
you got to let them fall on their face
and you got to let them figure out how
to get back up
at what age does this start though like
from the very beginning
when we
now i know a lot of people this is where
this conference remember i told you
earlier
how
we train our kids there's a lot of
people
that has disagreement on this
let's go let's talk about it i love this
conversation because i think it's a
powerful conversation and a lot of
people understand it because
they haven't tried it there's this book
when we grew up one of my good friends
gave me this book it was called love and
logic
and lovinglogic says that when you when
you keep a little baby when they cry
there's the time where they cry for
hunger and there's a time they cry for
attention
and when you
know they cry for attention you gotta
let them cry yeah
you can't go into the room and pick them
up because when you do that you're
training them every time they cry they
know mom and dad is gonna come get them
and we train them that way early on so
even when they are teenager
they do things because they want the
parents to help them so from the young
age
tammy's been the person where when
russell's husband's crying when they're
babies
she's let him cry
10 minutes 20 minutes 30 minutes until
they fall asleep
and cammy's mommy's always like you guys
are killing these kids and kevin's like
no i'm training them
to not to be reliable on us yeah yeah
it's called uh self-soothing too that's
right okay
and so today camisole have that same
mentality when russell hudson come up
because having a lot of money
is the easiest thing to do to actually
make it easy for them so i made a video
and i said
parents
stop making it easy for your kids let
them suffer
and i said
what i noted with the minority family
especially the oversea minority come
over here they come here and they work
hard and they say
i don't want my kid to suffer yeah i
don't want my kid to have a heart like
me i want them to they see not
experience this and i want to actually
work hard so i can make it easy for them
so they don't have to suffer right and
cameron and i say no we want russian
hudson to suffer not in a bad way but we
want them to learn how to figure it out
yeah and
every time they have it hard and every
time they can't figure out something we
jump in and solve the problem for them
or we jump in and actually buy them
something we now are building young kids
today right without being creative
yeah without being without having mental
toughness or they have building their
own tools without building on two yeah
right and we're not building kids with
grip today yeah because parents
we don't want them to actually
experience breakdown
but you want them to have breakdown
because that's where breakthrough comes
from yeah
the mental toughness and the creativity
comes in hard time yeah so the problem
is that the more money you have the
easier it is to actually do it for them
that's what my dad told my dad so he's
actually really proud of me he's a uh
immigrant refugee too
and so when he sees like all the
companies that me and joe have built and
then like the cool house that we have
like he's like i'm really really proud
of you right but he says but now
the biggest obstacle that you're gonna
face yes is
um not having your son grow up to be a
[ __ ] princess that's right yeah cause
he's like you have everything your son
he wants like one spider-man yeah his
sheets are spider-man he has two stuffed
animals spider-man spider-man pajamas
about two spider-man halloween costumes
and then he goes when you wanted
something when you were like three four
five six seven eight i'll buy you one
thing that might have satisfied eight
years or five years worth of things
right and he goes that's gonna be your
hardest job and this is where it's hard
this is where you guys have to draw the
line yeah and be the mom to let the kids
cry because part of the crying is
soothing part of the crime this is why i
love what jeff bezos said i'd rather
have a kid
with nine finger
that's
that who is creative yeah they'll have a
key with tan finger right and doesn't do
[ __ ] with them i don't do nothing with
it yeah and so the way to keep your kid
hungry
is you gotta actually teach them
how to fish versus give them the fish
right
and like i said also
i told my two boys when me and kami pass
away
we're gonna actually
give some of that money to them
when i pass away i'm gonna have billions
of dollars
i'm gonna do a warren buffett and
and
uh and bill gates says i'm gonna use my
money for good i'm gonna make the world
better
but i also gonna create a foundation
where i can do all that but my kids
they're gonna get some of that money but
they're gonna learn how to be
financially have spanish lucy they learn
how to learn how to be financial
independent they know how to manage
money to the point where they don't even
need the money they don't need the money
right and so this is why but it starts
now where i don't want to make it easy
for them yeah right right now russ and
husband they have to learn how to go out
there and hustle right and make money
i don't want to give
they have their own money they have
washing machine that they own they
actually collect money but they have to
go with their uncle to the property and
then learn how to collect the money yeah
right
because i want them to learn how to do
that i like that you share their story
to on your instagram yeah where like you
they they are already into like a couple
of hustles yes and then they're
understanding the entrepreneurial mind
and able to make little mistakes in here
where
uh if it's a financial mistake it won't
crush them that's right but it's enough
for them to learn to be better the next
time yeah so to keep your kids hungry
i'm gonna tell you
it's different when you got no money
yeah it different you don't have a
choice yeah right but when you got
option
it's easy to give that to your kids
now of course i'm i give them stuff for
their birthdays and this and that and
everything right
and but you leave the price tag on right
yeah i don't know they already know i
wouldn't buy this on sale okay yeah no
look at the price
but that's how me and cammy keep those
guys hungry right i always use this the
baseball analogy my kids they love
playing baseball
i can't
pay their coats to have them start right
right you got to earn that spot you got
to earn that spot right and you know you
guys are into you know support and
everything
after russian hudson you want to
actually start mom and daddy can't do
nothing for you we can't pay for it
you're going to have to put in the work
you're going to be hungry self-motivated
self-discipline go out there and
practice hitting those reps off the tees
over and over and over and over so you
can actually make the starting team and
you got to do it we can't do that for
you
that's the analogy i want to tell people
do that for your kids raising them in
the world of mental toughness in the
world financially you know financial
independence teach them all that
you can't do it for them that's the
problem where i see now parents with
money they're doing it for their kids
yeah they're paying their way for
college they're paying their way to get
him to start no yeah let them suffer did
you end up good suffering
yeah and also i think there's a huge
difference where
or people maybe who haven't reached your
level of success so they're not
understanding the game that you're
playing at your level right it's like
almost like uh like a junior high
basketball player trying to understand
what phil jackson is trying to do with
the nba i think you have to get to a
certain level where your mind opens up
to understand the level of strategy you
have and there's a huge difference
between
uh
suffering because you have no other
choice that's right versus i already got
my million dollar house right this is
controlled suffering for the greater
good of the future that's right bro yeah
and if they use used sports analogy
that's why the richest people out there
in sports i knew little league
they be like they be wanting to try to
get the kids like no your kids gotta
work just like any other kid to make the
team
so i say again
teach your kids financial literacy teach
them how to be a hustler teach them how
to be entrepreneur teach them how to
think teach you how to solve problems
teach how to be creative
just don't give it to them because there
is lesson
in the journey of of breakdown and
toughness and learn how to solve the
problem there is lesson there's more
lesson in there than just giving the
money and then them skip all that you
don't want them to skip that because
then you build a software when they grow
up yeah one thing that you do really
well that um i like that you prioritize
that i don't think we've kind of touched
on yet is the fact that
um everything that you've achieved
you've always kept family in mind and
your goal has always been balanced and i
think when you have that when you when
you show your your kids that you love
them and that you support them and
you're there for them
um i think that also creates a kid
that's going to be hungry and that's
going to want to like that they're going
to know that you always have their back
therefore yeah they might fail or it
might feel like the suffering part of it
but they know that it's because you want
them to grow yeah like my boy russell
he's just turned 16. we live in mercer
island right which is a very is it an
actual island uh it's actually an island
but it's still connected to seattle
through a bridge right yes sacramento
it's like coronado uh corona uh uh in
san diego coronado yeah like that
awesome beautiful and so in that
neighborhood pretty much every you know
everybody's pretty affluent yeah right
and so russell you know i mean he turned
16. and of course you know he won a nice
car
right
but we're like what is it what does he
want no you want a new tesla okay right
hey that's nice yeah nice you know that
that three model three yeah and i said
look
you can have a model three after you
drive this 1991 honda accord for one
year
and he was disappointed because a lot of
his friends already got audi's you know
bmw
why can't why can't i i have a nice car
matter of fact i make money from my
wife's why can't i just make the
payments on it because russo i want you
to learn
uh a patient i don't want you to just
always think everything's instant
gratification i want you to learn how it
is to be patient and learn and i want
you to teach you i want to teach you how
to be humble right i don't want you
always learning how to have nice stuff
so you can always try to flex you know
what i mean yeah i want you to teach you
how to have this because there's so much
lesson in that yeah
he understand but right he drive the car
you know i mean for a few months and
then also he go into breakdown like god
you know i i i want this and i like look
if you want i make a deal with you
i go 50 50 of you in the car
okay
you can go order the tesla put 250 bucks
down the car's gonna come in july right
this is like nine months already since
we talked about this conversation right
yeah
and
he put 250 bucks down when the car came
here
i i'll pay half of the car you pay half
of the car and i'll be half of your
insurance you pay half of the insurance
if you're hustling until now in the car
come and make your half of twenty
thousand because like four cars forty
five thousand you hustle and go find
half of the money
you can have the car in july when a car
do that and you're like you know what
done so now i got him thinking yeah all
right that's why he went out there
trying to do all this you know uh
bitcoin everything he's hustling he said
to me that day dad when's the next flip
let me get up in it oh nice
you see do you see the carrot i'm doing
yes that's the thing we want to teach
our kid yeah versus most of the kid on
the island
bam here's 45 here's a brand new car for
you yeah like i don't want to deal with
you don't even talk to me here you go
what i mean yeah right and so that's the
thing right and so i told him i got you
back dude but i want to teach you how to
earn this car versus giving you the car
yeah yeah that's the analogy and russia
knows right i'm teaching them this and
we sit down we talk about this and i
teach you how to be an entrepreneur
because i told them what i want you to
learn is more than a car i want you to
learn how to be a problem solver i want
you to absolutely
yeah and that's what we talk about since
you paved your path through uh
entrepreneurial spirit and mindset and
hustle um you pretty much like went
around the traditional thought process
of going through school and doing
whatever yep what's your thoughts on
like do you care if your kids go to a
prestigious school or anything or do you
care more about me or if they just care
about them finding their path and just
going straight there that's a good
question
there's so many people out there on
social media right now that
they always say right on social media um
you know going to college is a waste of
time
and i tell all the people who do that a
lot of them that say that
number one they probably didn't go to
college right number two they don't have
any kids
and it's you gotta be responsible on
what you say in social media because kid
will listen influencer and it will go
that's when said don't go to college
hear what i say by going to call with me
and cammy
i tell russian hussein you should go to
college
you should get good grades
all the way through elementary school
work hard good ace part of russell's
getting the car also he has to stay
getting three things russell got to do
to get his car one he had to come up
with half of the money he had to get
uh a's
he had to do good in baseball and he got
to be in a state of appreciation and
gratitude daily even with his honda
that's how he's going to earn his tesla
that's awesome okay yeah so just because
he got money he found his money but he
didn't get a's no you got to get a's
right
because i'm setting these guys up for
what is getting a's is it is it because
you're saying like it shows that you can
stick to something or you can i see
because i don't want them to be a dummy
entrepreneur yeah i want them to be a
smart entrepreneur yeah okay
because they could be rich and dumb too
that's right yeah okay and so i want
them to do that plus i want them to get
good grade because i want them to go to
college
now
i'm not attached
if they go to college
and they have some more time to think
about what their passion is
because i think sometimes when people
get out of school
they don't really know what their true
passion is yet yeah some people right
some people know right away
right
some people don't and they need time
some people they take off after high
school and they travel the world for
three years and then they come to find
their passion
and i said if you're not gonna do that
then go to college but let's be
strategic
if you're gonna be entrepreneur let's go
take economic class let's take business
class let's go take you know money class
let's do that
in college
so you can learn something good and you
can actually have time to find your true
passion
let's say after the first year they
realized you know what dad
i just went through all this i found my
passion what my passion is
i want to be a stock broker i want to be
a real estate investor
and i see that and i see the maturity in
that and they want to take off now early
go for it
but i want them to go there i want them
to meet people because i call this the
networking yes it's going to be
important for sure okay learn something
is important
so i don't care if they're finishing
that i want them to
go there
because if i tell my kids
college is important i promise you they
ain't gonna try hard to get good grades
all the way through high school
because like my dad said it's not
important so i'm telling everybody
unless you know you're going to be a
doctor unless you know you know what i
mean you're going to be a lawyer those
kind of thing where you got to go to
college
right boom but if you don't know
and you know
you're not sure
you need time to find your passion and i
tell my kids go
because you want to meet people you want
to network people you want to learn
something good and you got time to go
find your passion and when you're there
if you're going to get all four years
then you're going to know what you want
to do go for it halfway through if you
know what you wanna do then go what you
gotta do that's my whole thing yeah so i
don't i don't say don't go to college
and i'm not saying that for everybody
because there's some people that they're
gonna be doctored they gotta go because
you can't learn you can't be a surgeon
on youtube i hope not yeah yeah i hope
not yeah that's my whole thought on it
yeah yeah i know that's dope yeah uh we
would we would have kind of different
different seeing different views on it
uh where he was like you know i went to
college and you know i never applied
anything that i went to because you you
were he was trying to be a doctor uh he
ended up in comedy and just being a good
asian boy yeah but i found my passion
like my third fourth year in
in college yes and i was like why am i
doing that that's it there we go that's
the same amount out of you but also i
think my mom did a good job of raising
me where she was like you got to finish
what you start that's right so i was
like [ __ ] man i'm like one or two
years out i'm gonna finish i'm trying to
hit comedy like 100 that's right and
here's the thing you didn't know comedy
was for you before you enter college i
didn't know if you knew that was your
passion if that was your passion was an
actor or a basketball player then you
pursue it yeah but you needed time to
find it yeah and sometimes you can find
it when you travel in the world for
three years yeah right but if you don't
go to college because you might find
yourself doing comedy you might find
yourself being a ceo of facebook
whatever it is but that you know yeah
but that's a great example right there
bro yeah that's a great example of what
i'm talking about yeah no i love that i
don't think you wasted it because i
think that
you found your passion and you probably
met some great people you didn't but i
think it just
that was pat part of the path yeah like
it molded him yeah but sitting at home
doing nothing and didn't work at a
nine-to-five job at a rosie story gonna
do [ __ ] for you either yeah that's true
okay thank you to avenova for sponsoring
this podcast
avenova has pioneered the use of
hypochlorous acid or
hoci
something that our bodies naturally
produce to fight off toxins and
inflammation to rejuvenate our eyes
their patented fda cleared formulation
is the only stable and truly pure
solution in existence so if you suffer
from dry eye or contact lens discomfort
or anything else going on with your eyes
inflammation um styes
okay so for everyone listening right now
you guys are going to get 25 off avenova
um when you use code get close
25 at checkout okay that's 25 off at
avenova
using code get close
25. thank you to better help for
sponsoring this podcast okay listen up
because i'm talking about mental health
okay it is so so important because we're
just not taking care of our mental
health you guys every year it's required
of us
to get a physical
done right we go to the doctor and every
year we get that done uh every
six months we get our teeth checked but
how often are we paying attention to
what's going on in our brain i think
it's time we do that so please listen
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
think about that
if it the answer is yes well better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist okay
you'll be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
do not confuse this to a crisis hotline
it's not self-help you are literally
talking to a professional therapist
and this is going to be done securely
online okay which is beautiful because
some of these services are not available
for like like locally for some of us if
we live in a rural area we're not going
to have these resources so the fact that
we can do this securely online is
amazing and it gives us way more access
to so many more
licensed professional
therapists so please do yourself a favor
for listening to get close podcasts
we're hooking you up okay you're going
to get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
bill
that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
bill and you're gonna get ten percent
off your first month please
take care of yourself um when you were
saying that you were going door-to-door
and you were like uh you know 100 flyers
a day and you were thinking about your
why which is you know retiring your or
like providing for your for your parents
um
what did they do that you were like man
i really got to do this for them like
how did they raise you or you were like
just so about them and so about taking
care of them
as asian
the only thing they always say to you
and come home
you want something to eat
right we got you
and i was like that all my life even
today my mom called me just like hey
when you come home uh you know i've been
home today how i good you know and i
always go you know i always go spend at
least a day or two my mom i'm out of
their house because my dad passed away
right
and that's why they've been like from
day one and they work hard you know work
you know
warehouse you know and and that kind of
thing
and for me when i see that my dad was
social working come home and you know
he's tired and that was my number one
drive you know let me go out there and
make money and when i made enough money
right i mean the first thing we did was
i bought my dad a new forerunner oh sick
right yeah and i told hey come down here
to the dealership i bought this new car
i wanted to show you what i bought they
came down they didn't realize it was for
my dad oh and that was the first time i
saw my dad actually cry oh man that is
so rewarding
okay
and then
um then then um the next thing was i
paid off his house
sick okay what was that like were they
like in disbelief or were they like
finally right disbelief right
and then i remember my dad went on a
mercedes benz we bought him a new
mercedes-benz
okay
um i think the biggest one that i think
that really touched my mom and dad the
most
is the first time me and cameron went to
uh you know hawaii we loved it
and
and then i said to cammy we got to take
our parents
and i'm taking my mom and dad for the
first time to hawaii and they loved it
and we realized again
part of why i want to make a lot of
money is
i want to have my mom and dad and all my
spouse to experience the good life yeah
and so from that point on
every year i took my mom my dad all my
brother and sister and all the cameron
brothers and their parents to why every
year we're going to hawaii it was always
been paid by me every single year damn
that's gangster dude that is yeah and uh
and we did it for years until not too
long all the everybody still having kids
but i remember we was in oahu
and everybody's out playing on the beach
and my dad and i was walking on the
beach and he says
if it wasn't for you
we will never have this experience
and the more important to me
is all your brother and sisters would
never have this experience damn
so
i'm proud of you oh that's amazing dude
okay that's that's crazy because um
when it comes from like my dad's the
same way i grew up i'm mexican and
that's just not some [ __ ] males say and
parents no so if your parents in like a
minority
tell you like if you're minority your
parents tell you yeah and it's your dad
that they're proud of you it's like [ __ ]
because we always look up to our dad we
want to approve from them yeah yeah
and so that to me
was the thing that really made me happy
yeah because i'm sharing my wealth with
my brothers and sisters yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] beautiful that's awesome man
that's why
when
i get a phone call from my dad
one day he says leave camera at home
i want to come talk to you alone
i get to my mom and dad's house
and they're sitting on the sofa real sad
and i'm like what's the problem
and my dad gave me this little piece of
paper
and i read it
and it's
it said
cancer
oh
man
in that moment
like everything just fell out
thinking
oh
they can't be true
at 5 million already already saved up
and i told my dad
i got money
we're gonna save you mm-hmm
we're gonna go to the best doctor
we're gonna go to the best hospital
wherever we gotta go
we're gonna take you
stay positive okay i need to do
affirmation my dad every day when i see
him stay positive dad we got you man i
got a lot of money we'll take them empty
on my account we're gonna save you
i hate to take him to
go get his chemo
every month
they used to put ivs in them
and then you start losing weight you
don't have any more iv and they just
poke him in his arm hand
that's the hardest thing to sit in the
room man and see my dad just going
through pain
and then he he just got worse and worse
i remember
the nurse says
your dad's not going to make it anymore
we should send a hospice to your house
i think he's gonna go probably
in the next 24 hours damn
we're out of my dad's house
or everybody's their momma brother
everybody's home uncle
and he's down to like from 160 like 105.
he's laying in bed his eyes still open
and he's suffering
and i can tell he want to talk but he
can't say nothing
and i told my dad
i know
it's time for you to go soon
i don't know
you don't want to leave
until you know
who's going to take care of mom
who's going to take care of their
siblings
and i told them
i got you pop
i'm gonna take care of mom i'm gonna
take care of my brothers and sisters
and i'm gonna
carry the torch of all the things you
did
i'm going to keep getting the torch
i'm going to i'm going to be the next
lighthouse for you
i'm going to take care of it for you
so you got to go
you should leave
because i know it's painful
and at 30 seconds later then he passed
away oh wow
he just needed to hear
that i got him
damn and he left
damn
and that's why
my dad was the person that actually got
us over here yeah and for him to say
he's proud of me for sharing my welcome
my family
and take care of him all the way through
he passed away the town taking care of
my mom all my brother in them said he's
gone
and today
why i do what i do today
why i still work so hard every day and
it's not because i need it because i
already i have enough passive income to
live
but i do it because i told my dad
i'm gonna carry his torch
and i'm gonna continue to shine bright
in the world
and inspire and empower people
and see that anything's possible by me
sharing my own goals and dreams
and when people follow me on social
media
i want to inspire them to see that if
this cat can do it and he's still rich
he's still out there door knocking today
looking for deals
then anything is possible
so that's my vision today is to inspire
and empower
these people to reach for their goals
and dreams that anything is possible by
me just sharing my story every day on
social media and what i do every day
because that's my
promise to my dad
is that's how i'm going to uplift
everybody around me yeah and that's why
i do all the philanthropist work that's
why i do stuff with the seattle south
building
feel for soccer field i built houses and
i uh went up to affordable housing for a
family and my plaque with my dad's name
young's house oh you know what i mean so
i do that now this field that we're
gonna build for the soccer field that
we're doing with the south side i'm
gonna pack that with young's soccer fuel
that's beautiful
and that's why i do what i do that's why
i'm dedicating all this to my dad you
know me yeah yeah that's beautiful how
how uh
long ago did your pops pass 1997. he was
only in his mid-60s damn yeah
so that's why
when we
are alive
we got to live
and i always tell people
don't be so caught up trying to be like
everybody go find out what your passion
is
don't listen to your mom and dad telling
you what you should do listen to your
heart feel what your passion is and go
live
your life go live your passion
and don't do things for the wrong dude
reason doing for the right reason do
things that's aligned to what make your
heart sing
and that way when you are alive you are
living yeah
when you were uh
you know first starting out and really
trying to hustle and knock on a hundred
doors a day you know i'm sure that's
super tough
there's got to be a time where you're
probably questioning why you're doing it
or going back maybe i'll just go back
being a grocer that's probably easier
is there was there a pivotal moment
where you're like man [ __ ] this i don't
want to do this anymore
and like what helped you stay on the
path
the first year was the toughest for me
after i got my sixth deal after the
first year i realized
i just needed a little
miracle
to go there was
what i realized now and i teach my kid
this and i share this a lot of people on
social media
when we're on this journey
you gotta go
for something sometimes you won't be
able to see that go right away but you
can see the little small miracle on the
journey going there and you have to
really focus and acknowledging and
thanking god for those little miracle
because the more you can focus on the
little miracle the universe is gonna
keep on giving you more miracle to keep
focusing on and then that adds up to the
big thing you want what was one of the
miracles for you in the beginning at
least got my first sixth deal in the
first year
that was a big one because you were uh
was your goal only five and you got six
or the sixth one was just a huge thing
on its own my goal was just just making
it man just making it to the end of the
year yeah and just get something yeah so
you just wanted one yeah like if i do
one i did my job right oh [ __ ] and then
the second year
it was
less rejection
did you ever go back to the same homes
or you just brand new homes all the time
i go through 11 000 doors a year and i
go through the home twice a year
wow and every time i go it's just less
rejection
because they might be more familiar with
you
this [ __ ] guy's back again might as
well hear him out right
and and i just keep looking for a little
thing even today
today
even today man i still have to look for
little things to actually
really focus on because
that's stuff that i do today you guys
know you're on social media sometimes
social media you know you get a lot of
haters out there you get a lot of people
you know what i mean that just hate
there's lots of unhappy people with
their own happiness
right yeah rejecting it some video don't
do well than others you know what i mean
uh sometimes you know you go for months
and you know deal with not working out
right deal far on the part and i just
got to look for little things man to
really focus on right i have this saying
that says
uh uh uh the fastest way to financial
abundance is look for plea look for
pleasing that you already have in your
life hmm
so the problem everybody keep looking
for great financial abundance versus
being grateful for everything you have
in your life right even little things
yeah that you already have already yeah
right so i'll see my son draw something
like really beautiful
but then when i get a new rolex it just
feels better
and the thing about the nice stuff i
know my lifestyle is it's good all
sudden it goes away like next month it
does immediately immediately the next
role that comes out i don't even like
this one anymore immediately yeah it
takes really practice to focus on all
the blessing you already have in your
life
if you want to speed up the
manifestation in your life practice
focusing on and appreciating everything
you have already good in your life
that's the fast thing you can that's the
fastest
nitrous you can put in your car to get
to you go faster it's the craziest thing
very people don't don't do that yeah
they're just waiting for like it takes a
while to get there impatient yeah and
you also play your hat you place your
happiness on an external force rather
than an internal oh and you place your
happiness on getting the results yeah
right uh
it's you you know for me it's like
the more you can be happy what you
already have the more you see the
external stuff
um so at what point then were you like
um i can provide i'm a great provider
for my family for you know my close
friends
why why
push that further and now help strangers
like where did that come from that's a
good question
from the time i started
until the time my dad passed away it was
about thatch
being recognized
being seen
being known
being approved
right
um
being famous being number one
right me me me
and when my dad passed away
and i realized how much my dad done
to get us over here he's a social worker
he helped so many refugees get on
welfare and get into housing
and i realized after my dad passed away
i've been playing
so small
you thought you played big because you
have millions already yeah but to me
playing big
is when you go beyond yourself
because that's a whole other level that
people don't get that i call that the
level of significant
and it's interesting when you play that
level
you actually even make way more money
than you do when you go about yourself
because all of a sudden way more people
appreciate you respect you love you want
to collaborate with you want to do
things because you are living in a space
of contribution
you know
from the time then until my dad passed
it was about being is about
selfish yeah when my dad passed away it
was selflessness
and from there all of a sudden it took
off from me
and that's when it really changed for me
philanthropist really changed for me
inspiring power my vision came to my
life then that's where my vision came
from after my dad passed away because i
realized
making money and having rolexes and
rogues voices
right it's temporary
but when you get into the level of
significance
and you're leaving mark some people's
life
are you leaving marks in the world
it goes on forever yeah right and that
to me
is real legacy
it's not just a kid like i'm leaving my
family
but to me true legacy i call it
generational wealth
and it's not just my generation it is
not just money to me generation of
welfare teaching my kid
about entrepreneur being self-sufficient
and creating walk for them but to me
generation of wealth is
also teaching everybody out there how to
have money how to have this and that but
also teaching how to actually be a
contribution to the world yeah that to
me is generational wall that's true
legacy everybody tells legacy but their
family but to me legacy is the impact
you're putting on the world that's a
whole nother level of legacy yeah that's
beautiful yeah and that's uh that's
really authentic and i really feel that
from you um i know you had asked him a
question and and uh i think pertaining
to real estate and the amount of like in
detail depth and information that you
gave that you don't even know who this
guy is like you from a stranger to a
stranger yeah like you could have easily
been like oh yeah man we can always talk
about that later or given like a short
answer but like the amount of time you
gave bart
in like sharing that i was like whoa
like you're just a different type of
person i
i realized for me today
the legacy i want to leave
is i want to basically impact billion
lives
that's for me a billion specifically a
billion and the reason why i go on these
podcasts because i can't touch being
live by myself yeah but i can touch it
with you guys
yeah i can touch it with my man ben
baller's life yeah i can touch it with
this person this person so together like
i said earlier
when all of us have these opportunity
when we come together
and we do stuff like this
this is how we are all
contributing to the world
and touching beings alive yeah this is
beyond all of us right here yeah this is
what i'm talking about this is legacy
right this is contribution a whole
nother level beyond money
this is what i'm about to me for me
today that's amazing yeah you know like
um
you
reached your success through real estate
and it was almost kind of like uh
like a necessary
like you it wasn't like like what what a
lot of kids our generation or younger
they have this privilege of finding
their passion right oh i want to be a
graphic designer they get to go to the
best school or whatever for you it was
like and a lot of immigrant parents
they're they're just they just got to
find a way to make it work that's right
and they're just doing all kinds of
random things and you found real estate
and you blew up
um was there ever a passion of yours
that you just couldn't really
you know dive into because you're just
trying to make ends meet
when i started i didn't have a passion
for real estate
i had a passion for being a salesperson
talking to people yeah
which is still the passion today yeah
it's called inspiring power people yeah
i just happen to be
inside a vehicle called real estate i
see my wife cami is more of the business
person
she loved real estate more than me
okay yeah i had a passion
uplifting inspiring helping people
she had the business mindset
so i happened to be inside this car with
cammy
and we made real estate our vehicle
but then that platform turned into a
place for me to speak
about how to become successful
and i love talking about money i love
talking about real estate but i love
talking about mindset
about balance because my core value
today is
abundance
contribution
creativity
growth
joy
balance family
health and simplicity
we have a very simple lifestyle
and that's how we like it we don't have
an entrepreneur
i work out at my
house i only have
me my wife kami lorenz that's my whole
entire staff for everything i do
i get a hundred grand a month in passive
income from all my rental and they even
paid off you when it's paid off here in
the next 10 more year i have 200 grand a
month in passive income
but my monthly expenses my business and
my personal it's only like 25 30 grand a
month nice
that's amazing and i got rogue voices
yeah i got ferraris i got bentley's i
got all the gifts that everybody have
you got silverado though i got one of
those
but because
that's that's our core we want to be
rich
we want to have a lot of abundance we
also want simplicity in our life yeah
you know and so for me man that's that's
that's that's what you know really
inspired me camera because
everything i do we line it up to our
core value and if it's a line to a core
value we do it it doesn't lie to our
core value we're not interested smart
yeah i love it that's awesome that's
what we're trying to live too like we
our families is
the reason why we do everything right
and we try to make things as simple as
possible i think when we first got into
the space we were like traditional
content creators influencers and we
thought we were businessmen right so we
ran our company grew grew there was
maybe like
almost up to 30 people in just one
company
and then we had probably almost another
30 in our fitness apparel space
and then now we're sitting here managing
two companies with like 60 people
and then when we really thought about it
like business wasn't really our passion
it was reaching people right similar
yeah like saying yeah yeah same thing
with our comedy we try to reach people
in a certain way with our fitness we try
to reach people in a certain way we want
people to kind of uh work for their own
mindsets dominate humbly
and all that so we started bringing it
back down so we can spend more time on
why we started in the first place our
family here we go and the simplicity
actually
gives you more breathing space in your
mind oh seriously and you're just
happier too you're way more happy
because a lot of times people do so many
things out there they do it they don't
even know why they've been doing it we
were like that same we just i didn't
know either we're like oh if you're a
business you gotta add more people right
add another zero we need an office now
and they're just doing things for the
yeah how we had a big ass [ __ ] office
that we barely even used right and it
was kind of the flex a little bit it is
the flex thing people do more thing to
flex they don't realize it yeah and they
and here's the thing that's so
interesting and i know you appreciate it
when i say this
i know so many people that are
financially wealthy
and have financial peace of mind
but i know very few people that have
financial peace of mind and emotional
peace of mind yeah
that [ __ ] worth more than financial
peace of mind
okay hell yeah when you can't sleep at
night and you laying there in bed you
got millions and your mind don't shut
the hell up yeah that [ __ ] right there
ain't no money you can buy that [ __ ]
right there yeah none
yeah none
i agree with that okay
that [ __ ] right there is real right
there yeah okay that's what i'm about i
wanna be able to sleep at night and just
know my stuff's quiet
okay i'm doing things for the right
reason
and that to me is way more powerful do
you ever are you ever quiet but your
wife won't shut the hell up no
my wife is one who says shut the hell up
man
i'm like i ain't talking to my ego
talking
this guy's always talking [ __ ] about
what
but we can't do anything without you
yeah [ __ ] because
that's why i let you talk because we're
a husband and wife team too and
everything we've ever done we did it
together and it was it's been the most
amazing journey so far it's awesome bro
i i think that's awesome you know what i
mean yeah yeah that's awesome yeah i
love what you're about um we've actually
reached the end of our podcast and i'm
kind of bummed because i feel like we
just barely scratched we gotta go back
and do part two or three later yeah we
have to do that um before we let you go
though i know you're you're about uh you
know breaching mindset and and you know
trying to reach people is there anything
else that you want like one last
hurrah one last thought my last thought
is this there's so many young people out
there
right that are out there hustling
and out there looking for their passion
making a lot of money
okay which is good
and i want to tell the young folks out
there if you're out there listening go
make your money i don't care what you do
for a living doctor
lawyers nine to five entrepreneur
e-commerce
trading whatever you are doing out there
if you're making a lot of money
which is great but i want you to also
practice
not only
instant gratification but practice
patient
and i also want to teach you how to
create long-term wealth
take the money you're making you guys
just take some off the table i'm not
saying all of it take some off the table
and just buy some real estate and just
rent it out and hold it and just let it
ride finally get rented don't do airbnb
just put a nice tenon in there a nice
family just rent it and just let it ride
and raise the rent yearly a little bit
at a time
keep keep making your money i'm not
saying stop making your money keep
making a lot of money park some money in
rental and every time you have a little
bit of money buy another one
have make a little more buy another one
and i promise you
ten years from now
you look back
and you would thank me for actually
having millions and million dollars in
net worth
because you parked it you let it rip and
the thing appreciate you have write-off
you have cash flow you have and you have
appreciation
10 20 years now you're going to be
thanking me like man i'm glad i started
it early because now i have all this
nest egg
and i want to say this end of this like
this
i was making a million dollars a year
when i was young
then i started making 2 million bucks a
year
but by the time you pay taxes and
everything
and paying your bills you ain't going to
have much left over what i call savings
yeah
today i'm blessed to have
hundreds of thousand dollars a month
passive income
you just know i'm 51 years old by the
time i'm gonna die i'm gonna have a
billion dollars so you can all imagine
my net worth is very very high
i couldn't save my way to the net worth
i have today
if i only save money only yeah it was
the money i took
and i parked it
inside real estate
that gave me
even today and i started from nothing
to even have 100 a month in passive
income you can only imagine the net
worth yeah yeah
you can't save your money folks
do that
and have hundreds of million dollar net
worth
okay ever
so take your means that are you making
post them off the table parking real
estate because 20 years from now 30
years ago you look back
damn
i can't believe i have hundreds of
property
hundreds of million dollar net worth
hundreds of thousand dollars a month in
passive income
came from just taking a little bit of my
money and just parking it
so
get your instant gratification but also
practice your patientness and park your
money retirement otherwise you have
nothing down tomorrow so what's the
purpose working hard now you have next
for tomorrow yep that's why i want to
leave you all today
boom and with that i want to say thank
you so much you're such an inspiration
you're so motivation though um and and
we're so grateful to have you here um
thank you guys for tuning in and we'll
catch you next week peace